here is my theater your Majesty's Royal
Highnesses excellencies ladies and
gentlemen what brings about the great in
the world of literature often someone
seizes upon a simple discounted as in
the hyacinths afford and makes it mutate
at one point emerge the modern novel
from anecdote and letter so first in
dust rose drama in the new age thus
songs in the vernacular be thrown
learned Latin poetry thus - did la
fontaine take animal fables and Hans
Christian Andersen fairy tales from the
nursery to pond a seein Heights each
time this occurs our ideal of literature
changes in itself it would not be
sensation that a singer-songwriter now
stands recipient of the literature
literary Nobel Prize in a distant past
all poetry was sung or tunefully recited
poets were rattled parts troubadours
lyrics care comes from Lear Loren
but what Bob Dylan did was not to return
to the green or the province
instead he dedicated himself body and
soul to 20th century American popular
music the kind played on radio stations
and gramophone records for ordinary
people
white and black protest song of song
your country blues the early raucous
gospel mainstream music he listened day
and night testing the stuff on his
instrument trying to learn
but when he started to write similar
songs they came out differently in his
hands the material change from what he
discovered in Halo and scrap an old
rhyme and quick wit in curses and Pierce
prayers sweet nothings and true jokes
heap and poetry gold whether on purpose
or by accident is irrelevant all
creativity begins in imitation even
after 50 years of in uninterrupted
exposure we are yet to absorb music's
equivalent of the fables Flying Dutchman
he makes good rhymes SATA critic
explaining greatness and it is true his
rhyming isn't a chemical substance that
dissolves context to create new ones
scarcely containable by the human brain
it was a shock with the public expecting
poppy folk songs there stood a young man
with a guitar fusing the languages of
the street and the Bible into a compound
that would have made the end of the
world seem a superfluous replay at the
same time he sang of love with the power
of conviction everyone wants to oh all
of a sudden much of the bookish poetry
in our world felt anemic and the routine
song lyrics his colleagues continued to
write were like old-fashioned gunpowder
following the invention of dynamite
people stopped comparing him to Woody
Guthrie and Hank Williamson turned
instead to Blake bamboo Whitman
Shakespeare in the most unlikely setting
of all the commercial gramophone record
he gave back to the language of poetry
it's elevated Stein lost since
the Romantics not to sing of eternities
but to speak of what was happening
around us as if the Oracle of Delphi
were reading the evening news
recognising that revolution by warding
Bob Dylan the Nobel price was a decision
that seemed airing only beforehand and
already seems obvious man but does he
get the prize for upsetting the system
of literature no not really there is a
simpler explanation one that we share
with all those who stand with beating
hearts in front of the stage at one of
the venues on his never-ending - waiting
for that magical voice Shantha
made the observation that when a master
such as la Fontaine appears higher Kader
of genres the estimation of what is
great and small high and low in
literature is nullified Leo weaken what
matter the rank of the work when its
beauty is of the highest rank
he wrote that is the straight answer to
the question of how Bob Dylan belongs in
literature as the beauty of his songs is
of the highest rank by means of his erv
over Bob Dylan has changed our idea what
poetry can be and how it can work he is
a singer worthy of a place beside the
queen decide decide with the romantic
visionaries beside the kings and queens
of the blues besides forgotten masters
of brilliance standards if people in the
letter literary world grow one must
remind that the gods don't write they
dance and they sing the good wishes of
the Swedish Academy follow mr. Dylan on
his way wants to come in dance dance
[Applause]